all right we'll bring up a question from
mary who says a few shows ago you
mentioned that you hadn't heard anything
from the pulpit about the transgender
epidemic while i agree that this silence
could largely be attributed to cowardice
i wouldn't blame priests if they were
omitting mentions of the subject because
there are so many young children at
church my 11 year old niece is innocent
of any knowledge regarding the trans
pervasiveness she goes to my church and
i would feel inclined to take her
outside if the sermon were about those
issues in order to preserve her her
childhood innocence for as long as
possible does the presence of young
children seem to you like a reasonable
justification for keeping the topic out
of church do you think the topic should
be proactively brought up to kids at a
certain age to prepare them my instinct
is that the longer it can possibly be
avoided the better thank you and spg for
life
well i would say
a couple of things
i understand that that is it's a
difficulty dealing with this topic
dealing with abortion these are these
are really difficult topics there are
ways to talk about them that would not
be appropriate for kids you have to
decide at what age you want to expose
your kids to these issues and then once
you do expose them to it there's sort of
different levels of exposure
um so that is a difficulty that you have
to navigate
i understand that
that is not
a good enough excuse to
get all the pastors off the hook that
don't go anywhere near this subject i
just i don't buy
that
i think mary's being very generous you
know i don't buy that they're primary
concerns well it's not appropriate for
kids because if that was the issue then
i mean at a minimum there are things you
can do even if you're not speaking about
from the pulpit there are ways you can
engage on issues like this outside of
speaking about it from the pulpit you
could have you know you could
at least have groups in the church where
you talk about these things you have you
could give talks that are for adults you
could at least do that mostly churches
don't even do that um i think that there
are
it's just not an acceptable option i
would say
as a church to completely ignore
the issues that that your congregation
live in every day they live with these
issues every day it plagues them they're
worried about it
they're coming to church you know
they're sort of battered and broken out
on the battlefield of the culture every
single day and they come to church on on
sunday and you need to speak to to use a
leftist phrase you have to speak to
their lived experience
and to just ignore it like it doesn't
exist is not right it's also not it's
not helpful i mean this is what
your film right in so many of your other
films
you're dealing with
difficult topics
there's a way that you could talk about
it that would not be appropriate for
kids but you find ways to talk about
that that can speak to an entire family
yeah
i i agree with you um if this
mom has a moral conviction that she
wants to protect her children from
difficult uh
bad twisted perverted
polluted ideas
then my question for her is
are you also
not sending your children that little
girl to public school are you also not
allowing her on social media
because if you're are doing those things
then you have a double standard and you
don't really care about protecting your
daughter because
the
popular media and culture and public
education is raping the mind of your
daughter
daily and impregnating her with ideas
that will destroy her sense of identity
and moral value and everything else so
um
that's all that conversation's already
in her mind so i don't know how she's
clueless or has never heard of these
things
maybe you go to your kids go to a great
school but um
we live in a culture now where
you've got to talk to your kids about
these things because
you're
um fooling yourself if you think that
others are not talking with her about
those things they are yeah i don't know
how you could get
in this culture i don't know how you
could even get to the age of 11 or 12
and not have broached a subject i've
already talked to my kids about these
things i talked about that right my
first conversation with my kids about
something related to this was like when
they were five years old because
we're out in public and they see
something they see somebody walking down
the street and it confuses them so that
look that's daddy that's a that's a boy
but he's dressed like a girl
that's the first conversation that we
now have to have you and you you explain
in a very child you know in a way that
that connects with a child and what i
said to them is well this is someone who
is there are people that are confused
that someone's confused we should pray
for them
but that's the first conversation you're
already talking about it and as they get
older you just you need to keep that
conversation going
and what do you think about this and i
don't know exactly how where i would
come down on this but um i don't like
the fact that
those with perverted ideas are
determining the time frame for my
children to learn these things so wait a
minute i i really also don't like the
idea of talking to my five-year-old
about these topics because this is just
developmentally they're not ready for
this but i'm also not amish so i don't
have
you know uh hay bales uh you know
fencing me in from the rest of the world
so
what do i do and how do i how do i keep
my kids away from this stuff
as long as possible because i think
that's a good idea i think we should
keep social media away from our kids as
long as you can but then realize that
you're putting your kids together to
give them away and they're going to
interact with all of this stuff
eventually and so like you said
i want to determine the time frame and
say now is the time for us to talk about
these things but that's hard because
someone else has already kicked down the
door and said i'm talking to your kids
about it now yeah
yeah that's exactly right
if you want to join my exclusive fan
base or a cult as really that's what it
is we're joy we're forming a cult then
all you gotta do is click the subscribe
button and ring the bell below uh this
video to stay up to date with all my
content and if you want even more you
can watch or listen to my show at the
dailywire.com spotify or apple podcast
looking forward to welcoming you to the
sweet baby gang